infiltration
sabotage
exécution on est à fait des choses
terribles au service de la rébellion
d'or quoi que tu me dises quoi que tu te
dises à toi-même
à la fin tu mourras en combattant c'est
pourri de faire
est-ce que tu préfères pas frapper un
grand coup pour un vrai résultat
nous avons choisi notre camp nous
combattons le côté obscur
les rebelles ont lancé une campagne
ciblée et organisées envoyées des
troupes traqués et arrêter l'axe
rendez compte de la population va
souffrir
c'est le moment de les pousser à
l'erreur et ce sera à quel prix à tout
prix
à chaque jour qu'on laisse passer
ils deviennent plus forts
mais de plus en plus de citoyens se
rappellent ils ont peur je peux te dire
qu'ils ont vraiment peur
[Musique]